with me is kris bryant mr. Bryant the
bits of your speech that were circulated
at the weekend were pretty critical of
tesco and next here we are today you're
praising them for their employment
record what's happened what'd you get so
wrong I'm not this is not quite that
dramatic a change but if there's almost
change I read what you said at the
weekend you criticize them for tiring
work foreign workers on the cheap here
you've placed praised their employment
records and yet you said in answer to
questions you're not backtracking I'm
not backtracking I'm saying a very
simple thing and I've been saying it all
weekend I'm not saying that tesco and
next are unscrupulous employers I've
never said that never intended to say
that but I do think that there is a
problem that we have 1 million young
unemployed people in this country under
the age of 24 we've got areas of very
high unemployment where where youngsters
rinse is twenty three point eight
percent unemployed and yet and good
employers like Tesco and next have to
resort and maybe resort too early to
recruiting from outside the country and
in addition in some cases you have
recruitment agencies that advertise only
in polish I just don't think that's fair
I'm sorry but you were not calling them
good employers at the weekend in the
extracts that appeared in the Sunday
papers for example of speech now for a
girl hold on might be fuller but there
are a few omissions as well because in
the case of next you accuse them of
avoiding agency workers regulations
which apply after a candidate's been
employed for 12 weeks you talked about
polish temps there you left that out of
your speech if you have if somebody
dropped the allegation is working as an
agency worker they only start to get a
full set of rights after 12 weeks under
the legislation that came in in November
2011 so it is true that if an employer
decides to recruit people whether from
elsewhere in there EU or from in the UK
only on short-term contracts they do get
that the employee may get a tougher end
of the stick and my concern is that
where a local worker may have to have
meet mortgage costs and all the cost of
living in the UK somebody who comes and
is only employed for a few weeks fewer
than the twelve weeks and is put in
substandard accommodation
gets is able to undercut low and local
workers and I think that that's a
problem but you've dropped the
allegation the specific allegation
against next on tesco you said take the
case of Tesco who regionally decided to
move their distribution center in Kent
they say they don't have one in Kent on
there you you accuse the government of
gimmicks and urban myths I put it to you
that perhaps you're guilty of some urban
myths perhaps peddled anecdotally by the
Unites trade union I haven't spoken to
unite on this issue at all however in
relation to Tesco's in it's true that
they haven't got a place in Kent I was
always going to say Essex I was always
referring to and the situation in Harlow
where one distribution center was closed
and a new one was opened in dagenham
Robert Hal from the local MP has pointed
to the problems that many local workers
felt that they had when the new place
opened with fewer of the of the local
work workers than in the previous
factory distribution center and I think
this is an issue around the whole of the
country where you where local workers
feel that they are effectively priced
out of the labor market we need to do
more to tackle that are you admitting
now that Labour got it wrong on
immigration when they were in government
and was soft on immigration John you've
asked me this about I don't know 20
times are there in private or on air and
I've said every single time what I will
say again now which is that when we were
in government I accept that we did get
some things wrong on immigration in
particular when the new countries joined
the european union in 2004 France
Germany and Italy said you can come and
work here in seven years time we just
said you could come and work here from
day one that was a mistake it meant we
were so focused on economic growth that
maybe it was understandable but it meant
that far more people came from Poland
Estonia and Latvia to the UK than we had
thought so yes I accept that we made
some mistakes but that doesn't mean that
we can't make criticism of the policies
at the moment that I think are failing
Gordon Brown in 2007 at the t you see
talked about British jobs for British
workers is that where you're saying no
I'm not I'm simply pointing to the fact
that there are 1 million unemployed
youngsters in this country and in one of
the areas and where
next took on a large number of
short-term workers from Poland this
summer and last summer to help with
their sale and I understand that
sometimes companies have to have to do
that in that area you have twenty three
point eight percent youth unemployment
we as a country and employers in some
industries in particular need to think
how we can make sure that more of our
young people are able to go into work